one of the top names in the Democratic
presidential race is out of the contest
senator Kamala Harris suspended her
campaign yesterday saying she just ran
out of money her communications director
tweeted this video last night showing
Harris dancing with campaign staffers in
Baltimore there's a good ole electric
slide I know it well
that O'Keefe is covered in the campaign
2020 it's a great dance cuz you can do
it all by yourself and was this
considered a big surprise in advance it
was to some for sure and it's the
biggest departure yet from the crowded
race aides tell us the senator spent the
Thanksgiving weekend conducting an audit
of her campaign and realized it would be
too expensive to continue she launched
her bid for the White House on Martin
Luther King jr. Day and later with a
huge rally in her hometown of Oakland it
all ended with a frank video message to
supporters I've taken stock and I've
looked at this from every angle and over
the last few days I have come to one of
the hardest decisions of my life
senator Kamala Harris made the final
decision to get out of the presidential
race late Monday night aides cited
several factors for her exit first she
likely soon will have to be a juror in a
weeks-long Senate impeachment trial a
responsibility that would keep her off
the campaign trail
another factor she hinted at Mike
Bloomberg I'm not a billionaire
I can't fund my own campaign but
Bloomberg can and just ten days into his
race he's already spent more than 52
million dollars more than double what
Harris has raised all year
Harris launched her campaign with 20,000
supporters in her hometown of Oakland
California
she peaked after the first democratic
debate last summer with a blistering
attack on former Vice President Joe
Biden
do you agree today that you were wrong
to oppose busing in America she surged
but then stumbled as she struggled to
explain her position on health care a
top concern of Democratic voters and her
campaign couldn't decide where to
campaign ultimately she settled on Iowa
recent reports detailed struggles
between her sister and top advisor Maya
Harris and consultants who'd helped her
win races in California but at the
debate in Atlanta two weeks ago Harris
insisted everything it was fine
I am focused on this election and doing
what is necessary to win period among
those who mark Harris's departure
President Trump he retweeted news of her
exit last night and the senator shot
back tweeting quote don't worry mr.
president I'll see you at your trial
Harris's exit means that potentially
millions of dollars from wealthy
California donors who backed her are now
up for grabs and polls showed that much
of her support came from the Golden
State which hands out the most delegates
for this nomination on Super Tuesday on
March 3rd which means the California
primary far more interesting now then we
might have another one she's out of the
race but still in it in other ways thank
you very much we'll see at 8 o'clock
back at the table I'll be here